Você sabia que algo que provavelmente
você come todo dia pode ser um aliado
poderoso contra o câncer? Olha só que
descoberta incrível que acabou de sair
na revista Cell Reports Medicine.
Pesquisadores descobriram que a Za
Chantina, esse pigmento natural que dá
cor às frutas e vegetais, pode realmente
apoiar, dar suporte ao combate ao
câncer. Nos estudos com corredores, ela
conseguiu retardar o crescimento de
tumores e quando foi combinada com
imunoterapia potencializou ainda mais os
resultados do tratamento. Pois é, a
zechantina já era conhecida por proteger
nossa visão, mas agora descobrimos que
ela estimula as células TCD8+, que são
justamente aquelas que destróem as
células tumorais. É como se ela desse
uma forcinha extra pro nosso sistema
imune trabalhar melhor contra o câncer.
Veja bem, você encontra zhantina em
alimentos que provavelmente já estão no
seu cardápio na sua mesa. Gema de ovo,
pimentão amarelo, milho, mamão, manga,
espinafre, rúcula, couve, alimentos
simples que podem fazer uma diferença
real. Yeah.